crisis on Infinite Earths has given our
verse fans a first big crossover moment
between the DC film and TV universes
with a surprising run in between movie
flash Ezra Miller and TV flash Grant
Gustin but there's more to the shocking
cameo the meet ci crisis on Infinite
Earths executive producer Marc
Guggenheim opened up to Entertainment
Weekly revealing just how involved DC
Comics chief content officer Jim Lee
actually wasn't pulling off one of the
TV season's most exciting and unexpected
appearances saying basically I was
working really hand-in-hand with Jim
from the moment he found out that this
was a possibility too once we knew Grant
Gustin was cool and on board with it and
Ezra was on board with it I would send
drafts of the scene to both Jim Lee and
TC entertainments film VP Adams Laghman
and we would just go back and forth as
Marvel and DC have expanded their screen
presences over the last decade they've
had to contend with one glaring issue
how their cinematic universes fits in
with the television ones it's been
especially tough for DC which has had
more luck among critics and fans with
its animated and TV show properties then
it has with its movies up until now the
CW lineup especially has been key to
DC's small screen dominance and bath
because it hasn't tried to merge it with
the film division it's a narrative
ecosystem in which writers drop Easter
eggs about ROM production into another
but usually do nothing beyond that which
makes Miller's crisis appearance the
most serious and significant attempt at
a DC cinematic TV connection to date
it's also won Guggenheim and Lee were
very careful with executing for the sake
of our universe Jurgen Haim Toni W the
trick with the scene is they didn't want
me to do anything that stepped on the
toes of the flashpoint movie that
they're developing so we worked really
hand-in-hand Jim was really great about
just making sure that all the parties
were talking to each other that nothing
was getting stalled he was a cheerleader
when he needed to be a diplomat when he
needed to be they may have taken a
carefully planned approach to writing
the Bary meets berry exchange but how
Miller's cameo came about was much more
impromptu in a variety interview
Guggenheim revealed that Warner Brothers
television president Peter Roth reached
out with a proposition after arrow had
wrapped and the crossover was nearly
completed when Roth asked how a
Guggenheim would
able to do it the EP responded with yeah
I know but if you're telling me as
ramela can be in the crossover I can
make it happen
Guggenheim Roth and Lea delivered
something many fans thought was an
improbable dream but it was one that
writer director podcaster and all-around
King of geeks Kevin Smith alluded to the
possibility of during a segment cut from
DC's dawn of the Justice League TV
special during a 2016 episode of his fat
man on Batman podcast Smith recounted
his conversation with DC creative
officer Jeff Jones saying DC is known
for nothing if not a multiverse so at
which point I was like could they
crossover Millett may have also puts out
positive vibes for a possible crossover
while pushing off a bits of controversy
around the DC film size decision to cast
him instead of merely using Gustin who
was already playing the speedster on TV
in a July 2015 interview with MTV News
the flash star called the existence of -
Barry Allen's quotes awesome parallel
universe all good casual fans will
undoubtedly see Miller's cameo as a dope
a one-off moment but for those a bit
more up to speed on the comics and
various screen universes the
implications are way more exciting to
start the running confirms the existence
of a multiverse through Miller's
appearance something that's corroborated
by gustin's line it should be impossible
now impossible now technically it
shouldn't be possible and yet they're
the two Barry's were proving that DC may
have finally settled on the multiverse
as the official answer - and connection
between it's big and small screen
stories but there are also hints about
the version of Barry Allen viewers can
expect in Miller's upcoming flash film
after being repeatedly delayed and going
through multiple creative team changes
the flash movie is pretty difficult to
get a read on over the years of the
film's beating developments it's become
less clear what exactly audiences are in
for when the and EMU Scotty directed
movie finally premieres in 2022
however the crisis on Infinite Earths
cameo did help decipher some of that
during their brief encounter both
flashes weighed the possibility of being
face to face for different reasons
as the cameo scene illustrates Miller's
Berry was way less than no than his
counterpart his general confusion over
where he is as well as how he arrived
there reveals that he may be
significantly less experience than
gustin's berry when it comes to his full
metahuman abilities and his knowledge of
the multiverse it's a perfect place for
a film which will reportedly be based on
Andy Kubert and Geoff Johns flashpoint
novel to start Bella's final line in
crisis on Infinite Earths also doubles
as a nod to fellow Justice League member
cyborg and serve as confirmation that
berry may bring his newfound knowledge
of the multiverse to his upcoming
standalone film
additionally the scene also seems to
introduce Miller's Allen to a superhero
named believe it or not also the flash
goes all the way that makes sense of the
2022 movie serves as an origin tale for
the DC EU speedster and that's a story
in which is already a fully fledged hero
with how well Miller's Barry's seemingly
takes for the moniker fans could maybe
look forward to seeing a nod to the
crossover moment from the big-screen
speedster in his forthcoming movie well
as remilia's crisis cameo was but a few
minutes long it may have played a
pivotal role in connecting DC's
universes moving the troubled franchise
forward and launching one of its
best-known superheroes into a new
adventure check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos but your favorite movies and TV
shows are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and to the pal
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]